did andy just say
oh my ipad's still on out of nowhere get
out get away from me lartz
uh okay where do we want to go let's go
to weapons
she's out of a [ __ ] this is weapons
okay i always feel like this shit's a
trap
to get me to go to the place
this is how i die you know what i'm
saying
no he's helping okay
okay all right everyone okay okay yeah
i'm all right okay
don't you be that far up in my [ __ ] oh
what
okay that's new what are y'all doing
here wait where
those two seem to trust each other or
they're like oh oh oh oh
somebody [ __ ] dead who was it two
people
john's yeah two people i walked into i
think it's the reactor room in the very
bottom and just realized that there was
a dead body
i walked by andy once and that was it i
walked by
bruce i walked by i think that [ __ ]
i've seen amara yeah i was hanging out
with alana i was like it seemed like i
was chasing her but i
was trying not to yeah i only saw
well i mean i i feel like i saw alana
doing tasks and alana was one of the
ones that we went up
like everybody ended up in the reactor
room at the end and she was the one that
actually did it i think
that's great yeah i went in there and
farley had already
had his hand on the thing so i went back
to watching cameras and didn't see
anything there
well ricky yeah ricky definitely you
definitely went to help by
i have no opinion though really i just
saw a yellow dead body
so well there's two imposters and if we
skip a vote then that means we have to
vote next round
um so did anybody see lawrence i didn't
i saw i feel like i saw long lawrence
early on with like a gas tank thing but
i don't know
i was in the upper right section of the
ship and i guess no one else was there
um i was just kind of knocking off tasks
which i understand is suspicious
it was something locked a door did you
skip or vote i voted for omar because of
last round
wow well i will say when i got into the
room i think the only two people i saw
leaving that room obviously it could
have happened at any time
were omar and
i'm gonna vote for myself maybe folly i
don't remember it was yeah it was either
follow addiction here's the thing here's
the thing it could be bruce because
there's two people dead and
uh he was it could be a cool community i
don't know what to do i don't know what
to do i don't know
i just ran out of time bruce bruce
looking ultra suspicious as the only one
voting
all right well good good luck oh he's
right though
[ __ ]
okay that didn't go great and i didn't
even get to finish my damn
task folly
lawrence
don't trust any some of my [ __ ]
all right same thing
okay electrical i've died in here before
many a time folks
what do you i think i trust ricky i
think i'm okay with ricky
so far this is a good place for me to
get trapped if any of those three saw me
come in here though
[ __ ] you doing you guys
what are you doing
i feel like i'm going to die
i don't like this at all this is not
good
did why did it look so much like they
were just waiting for me
what the [ __ ] was that
okay i reported the body oh [ __ ]
bruises wow
and so check this out i'm running
towards
nuclear to turn off whatever alert there
is and omar runs by me
whether he was in that nuclear thing on
the far left or not i i cannot say
but he really i was spending a lot of
time in the security room i'll say two
i'll say two alana left electrical and
went the opposite direction of reaction
yeah
and farley and i both verified each
other by dumping trash
oh i was gonna say you two are being i
was like you two are mad suspicious what
the [ __ ] were you doing
just standing there while i was doing my
electrical [ __ ] we both did the trash
shoot elana so you can't really
say anything to switch us up right now
well yeah
no i feel like i believe them with how
candidly that just came up but i was
suspicious of the two of you standing
there when i was doing my [ __ ] i was
like you two are going to kill me but
you didn't
understand that was staying with
lawrence yeah okay so then
andy what's what are you up to right now
what's bruce's body where who found the
body
i found the body it's in the far left
wherever the alert is that you got to do
the
i don't even know what the [ __ ] thing
is yeah i don't even know what it asks
you to do because i found his body first
and reported it first
but i i was on the very very bottom left
doing
um the [ __ ] thing where you line up
the line
like you got a yeah that thing down line
ran up omar
uh yeah we ain't got a lot of time left
ricky what were you doing
i was running toward towards the reactor
i was in the cafeteria running left
his name i left i left the uh the i was
looking at the security cams was going
down to one of my tasks but then
the reactor pulled me back towards lords
i'm voting a lot of lawrence
what i could have killed what what
oh my god okay those two are suspicious
those two are [ __ ] suspicious ran the
opposite direction
what
this is stressful and not saying what
what what is here yeah
is that a pro play
hey man no
[ __ ] [ __ ]
come on alana tillman alana i i uh the
very beginning because
first i'm here i was just outed i
definitely didn't kill anyone
it wasn't you i absolutely didn't kill
anyone no
he was so confident i was 100 not me
i was absolutely so confident because a
lot of people talk
wait did omar omar kill a youtuber
yeah yeah he killed me
i'm really glad you guys voted for me
you sons of [ __ ]
i i killed all of the people holy [ __ ]
guys remember when i voted for elmar do
you guys remember that yeah
i was worried about ricky i hunted bruce
because i was like well
if he's alive for one more vote thing
i'm going to go down
yeah absolutely you are sons of [ __ ]
we should have followed andy from her
dude lawrence why did i get voted out
there i don't understand what i did
wrong
you went the opposite direction yeah
because it's cool because
why is that a problem because reactor
was going off yeah but there were two
so i went to the to the arrow that you
guys were not going to reactor's all on
the same side
and i feel like i had an arrow in a
different direction or i was trying to
avoid you i don't even remember
laurence and finally because they were
still hanging out together like
at that point they were still just
running around together i was like oh
like it'll be so easy to accuse them if
we yeah
i was i was suspicious of them for that
yeah two people are there
lawrence oh sorry i haven't can't play
again there you go
chad you can't tell me that i gotta go
after omar harder
when i didn't see him in the room i just
saw him run i saw him run from
a random in that direction a bunch of
backseat gamers yeah
this game is like they get such a hard
on for it
i [ __ ] hate this i hate being i hate
it i already feel sick
i absolutely hate it it's truly the
[ __ ] worst could just
not do it i don't i don't know what i'm
supposed to do here really
here we go okay and hopefully john
handles that
no no there's too many on this [ __ ]
ah what do i want to do here there's too
many of them but i [ __ ] hate it so
much it makes me so nervous
uh i just need to find someone by
themselves
i feel like i'm shaking i hate it
well well well okay who was in
electrical with me
that i i just left you were walking
towards electrical as i was leaving
electrical
no i saw that i saw lana and i think it
was was it
rick no it wasn't man i don't know what
electrical is but addiction came in
[Laughter]
bottom
[Music]
i just went to the top right and i saw
ricky and i didn't see anyone else
i didn't even pass anybody did you bury
it well i
i ran past john and lawrence lawrence
was sitting in the dark when the lights
were off
in the navigation room do you want to
miss us that's a bit scary
i was doing a task and omar was shooting
the lasers
how close did you get to him omar i well
i got close enough because the
the scope thing was real small right i
got close enough got freaked and moved
out of the way
because he just popped out of nowhere
because if you just walked by and you
spotted him in there you're definitely
imposter because it's like you can see
no no there was i was uh i was
uploading navigational data okay yeah
and
i was doing uh i was doing the the
weapons thing i was shooting
shooting missiles for or uh meteors for
a little while
hmm john verify omar john walked by me
uh at the bottom of storage and i was
doing the water [ __ ]
along with the leaf [ __ ] i i got nothing
i'm minorly suspicious of lawrence right
now
me too i'm gonna i'm gonna do that
i'm just lauren the guns firing outside
when omar was doing asteroids
i did see the guns firing okay
wait do the pos imposters know each
other that they're imposters
yes yes
i hate it you know it's that's the
problem is i [ __ ] hate it it's like
oh this is
you know we just see lawrence a little
bit make him seems us
it didn't go in that direction but last
round they were like we gotta go for
someone in round one and this round
they're like no we don't have to do that
and i'm like okay what the [ __ ] are we
doing
then i have a countdown right now anyway
okay someone's an electrical
nobody is in electrical
where the [ __ ] are they all
how am i not seeing [ __ ]
okay feel good about that one keep
moving
i hate it i hate it is
do people find this fun and what is
wrong with them
um
let's just go to storage i suppose you
know you know what i'm saying [ __ ] i'm
so sorry
[Laughter]
this isn't storage where is it pop one
another one
that was i shouldn't have done that
well this is my task okay here we go uh
oh i can't actually do them got it i
don't feel like i need to sabotage
fine that make it progress so we could
[ __ ]
all right i guess we can throw all
suspicions of lawrence out the window
yeah all right okay i was on
i was on security cams the whole [ __ ]
time i saw
i saw john walk up to me i saw like a
yellow figure walk up to me nothing
happened
and i didn't see who killed the body on
the far left because that's the body i
just reported but on
cams all i can say is diction is running
into every room
just so super nice
i literally just did the uh the leaf
blower thing
the animation you did the leaf thing and
then you walked to the right and then
you
like walked up and then you went back
right and you went down and i was like
i thought i was done with my past and
then a new task popped up so i had to go
back down
and you tossed it popped up tell me you
saw that right
in navigation uh i
i don't know i don't know okay look i'm
not i'm not accusing
but i i haven't been alone with diction
at all so
i haven't seen dictionary if you did
you'd probably learn that i'm a really
nice guy john
i was alone with you in navigation all
right well that could be dixon that
could be you
and then farley you guys could be the
killers um true
andy could be big braining this on the
cameras the entire time as the killer
mm-hmm and then reporting it that's true
i can vouch for john so i'm going to
vote for addiction god damn it
i think that's fair i think i'll
you and electrical vote no one around i
could have yeah but you could have had a
kill time three people are dead
i haven't seen alana at all right next
to me when i did that when i flushed
the leaves out she saw me i didn't see i
100
didn't see [ __ ] now you're more
suspicious that means i vote for farley
next round
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh kill me okay so what's the strat
right now
bruce can stay i think i maybe want to
get rid of andy
i will just pretend to do this
if i just don't do anything and they
just
sort their own [ __ ] out like maybe i
don't have to kill anyone and they'll
just [ __ ] play themselves
oh i should kill someone
the omar kill was very clean i got real
lucky on that that was
i don't have to worry about anyone i
[ __ ] hate this though i feel like my
hands are legitimately sweaty and [ __ ]
so let's i don't know stand here for a
bit no point
where the [ __ ] is everyone
okay let's go pretend to do this i guess
like i got
this map is not too big and i too scared
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh god i hate it john you're nuts bro
so andy the minute that you said that
you were on the cameras the whole time i
was like
you probably see me slaughter omar then
or what
no i didn't see that do that i was over
there trying to play [ __ ]
simon or whatever messing it up a bunch
of times
i was trying to figure out my strat for
this last round and i was like well
bruce can stay because bruce is not at
all suspicious
i feel like we maybe like who do we kill
i thought it was far libro yeah i think
we would that's
okay so i was at that last point i
didn't realize i was going to win when i
killed andy but
it was farley and andy and so i killed
andy thinking
oh nice possibly accusing
oh i didn't know but i kept being like
maybe we don't have to do anything i was
like maybe we could just let them
fight it out themselves and we don't
even have to kill anyone
i knew it was a huge red flag when john
started accusing me because so far he's
never been accusatory
like anyone he just goes with the flow
but this time he was like yeah i don't
know about diction
we would we would complete the task too
are the ghosts doing their tasks
we did yeah i did literally all of us
were just floating around with nothing
to do at the end there
okay yeah i was done i [ __ ] hate it i
hate i hate being
the imposter so much my hands shake and
i'm like
confession i was not done with my tasks
i was just so scared of parliament
[Laughter]
okay where are we dropping boys admin
thank [ __ ]
i'm still legitimately like actually
shaking ah
being bad not does not compute with my
dna
um all right i feel like i was raised in
a way that i am
boring good okay let me grab that and we
swipe that
fast you [ __ ] son of a [ __ ]
what kind of [ __ ] is that okay
oh god okay okay all these rounds have
been really chill so far too
oh it's been done
get away from me
um
okay well i do need to go to electrical
but i got scared
i got scared what
what happened
oh sorry i forgot to turn the thing off
hang on hang on hang up there you go
because i was hiding the code everybody
calm down calm down calm down i can't
look too
oh oh i didn't know that was a thing
okay there we go
all right everybody chill out i fixed it
okay okay okay okay let's go here
why are you still yelling oh you're
thanking me that's okay we're that's
allowed
that actually did work though because i
try not to look at the chat because you
guys was faming i did notice that was
actually helpful thank you
it was andy i just saw him talking it
was ricky that was ricky andy and i
verified each other we both saw it
happen it was
it was ricky and he's definitely
laurence and andy right now because
they're they're co-opting together to
make it look like it's
absolutely not me ricky had a phenomenal
kill and ricky tried going for the vance
and also lawrence and i verified each
other we both did the body scan
i saw lauren student right in front of
me we did the body scan up there and
that med whatever [ __ ] just because
you guys are good at bullshitting
doesn't mean you didn't kill bruce in
cold blood
bruce verified us both and he would he
would stand by your words if he were
still alive
bruce is dead at your hand ricky okay
i'm voting
i'm telling you it's andy and i think
lawrence is in cahoots
well you know based on what just i'm
accusing you right now my own eyes
you're gonna regret this we're wrong
then you guys will win immediately
there's enough people with that locked
door let's find the second killer
everybody
okay lauren stay with me
i need to go to electrical but now i
want to stay with these two because
because then i won't die you know what
i'm saying but then they're going to
think i'm suspicious
we won't we won't do it we won't do it
all right what's happening john is
acting outrageously suspicious he
went to the laser cannons to assumedly
verify his
innocence however no lasers emitted from
the ship
all right so we vote john and it's
definitely not lawrence we've both drawn
ggs everybody
why what all right okay
that was fine it was actually just early
but if you guys are the [ __ ] killers
this is galaxy brain [ __ ] i mean
it's okay well you all voted for me
already but it's definitely lawrence
what makes you say that john what's your
defense today absolutely not me or
lawrence
although this would be a great way to
play my one if it's hard
well i wanted to stick with you because
i knew you guys wouldn't kill me
for the record all right
i don't know how to defend myself
okay first of all bruce you gotta turn
off the thing where it like uh
where's keeping it off no i'm not gonna
dig
yeah what are you guys doing to hide the
code or are we just not hiding i don't
know which ones it hasn't the code
hasn't changed it looks like um
the
and the weapon the asteroids in the
weapons room
i can make i can make less like long
tasks or short tests
maybe another short term oh no i think
it's fine i think it's balanced
yeah it's okay yeah it feels balanced
but ricky's upset because he killed me
and everybody saw so
um i've i've shared this room code a
number of times
yeah i was gonna say it's bound to
happen eventually i had done it like
twice so um yeah because i thought we
were changing every time
we would kick him yeah so then it'll
just stay the same anyway right isn't
that like the problem
uh well we can make a new one for a new
map yeah i could just
start i've never played another map
there we go it's fine yeah yeah they got
a they got a john carpenter
another farley okay new code
yeah yeah i thought because i thought we
were changing every time i was like who
cares if i show it you know i've given
it away
too it's it's not easy to keep it hidden
everybody's yeah
well it is i just have an image that i
pop up but i didn't think we'd need to
at the start
um okay
oh no yeah chad i don't know why the
overlay is so small i put
like big icons on the overlay and
they're still super tiny
we'll do uh how did you even get it to
work they're never gonna be happy eddie
you just gotta let it go
if you go to discord settings um like
your app settings or whatever and then
the middle of the app settings is game
activity
and you have to allow among us to do
game activity
among us
chad help me out shout out to check i
got it
hello asian boy i just played with him
yesterday and then new code is in
discord right now you guys ready nobody
show it
yeah nobody's throwing something showing
it here we go now
all right oh whoops are you serious
europe on europe here
your overlay is over all of the uh
oh i don't want to be brown
all right so let me try this one more
time i'll turn on the other you can move
it like bottom left john or bottom right
how do you do it how do you do it uh too
much work um
so you go to that the gear user settings
okay
and then um in app settings category i
think like fifth
the fifth thing is game no it's game
activity game activity got it
and then you have to like allow it to
work there there's like a toggle overlay
on
for among us yeah let's try that
do we have 10 now i don't know
and then obviously in the overlay
setting uh bar as well
who the hell is truck yeah who's that
sometimes there's like doubled up room
codes and [ __ ] did somebody show the
code is that what happened
well so we didn't have 10 people uh did
anybody show the code
no i don't think i did all right i'm
kicking quickly i did it
so who's not in whoever's not in should
join there we go here we go
all right we have ricky mm-hmm i just
want to make sure we got ricky
it was it was not letting me in sorry
that i just got in yeah yeah that's we
had someone else in time
okay here we go let's do it uh mute eli
i'm mutant definite pardon me
oh oh okay yeah mutant definitely when
you're playing
thank god just stay good you know what
i'm saying
okay well launch pad okay let's do this
one real quick
oh this one takes ages doesn't it yeah
you have like white or whatever
okay um i've lost myself
no i'm at the launch pad let's go across
to med bay shall we and then again i
just
i literally have to come back all right
bro all right that's going to take about
a minute
hot minute
[Music]
recognize my scan i've been verified
pretty sure you want to get scanned if
you're good
i'm clear
somebody else dealt with that [ __ ] uh
launch pad thing now it's still 40
seconds
so that means um we also verified eli
right is that what happened
[ __ ] of florence get away from me
lawrence
i don't want to die
any minute now anyone email the [ __ ] is
good strike
oh wrong way i'm supposed to go to admin
i can't believe that noise just came out
of me for that long okay
this is what i have to do
there's been so many people around that
it's like we're sort of safe here oh i
think eli is definitely safe right
yeah uh okay
seven eight seven eight six three
four boom yeah tight
okay mandy andy
react
this is the one that's down here to go
through the [ __ ] airlock to get to it
okay okay okay okay
uh oh oh [ __ ] what up interesting
i reported the body i was just in the
room with alana doing the [ __ ] card
[ __ ] where'd you see the body i was
uh in the room across from it on the
left side
okay but from what i witnessed
addiction's dead dixon eli and alana are
safe they all did the body scan i
waited there just waiting to watch them
i did see you watch us which made you
seem not suspicious
uh i can i can confirm the same of eli
watched him getting
i'm trying to cancel out people i'm
trying to make sure that i am safe with
other people's addiction eli and alana
are safe i've repeated
nine times in my [ __ ] uh chat uh so
dixon is dead now but eli and alana are
safe
eli you're muted by the way yeah i know
i can bear i can validate john and
farley i'll vouch for them and bruce but
bruce is dead
so that's too many
unless it's definitely ricky and john
so then it has to be ricky sorry ricky
and omar are the only two that we've not
verified when the alarm went off and
started going down
john if you're accusing me right now
when i just had multiple people verify
that i was body scanned that's
suspicious as [ __ ]
yeah i took it back because i remembered
when when we were imposters
you were playing it cool so i take it
back
what did you see like you pointed like
four different fingers there which was
what made me suspicious but
i have like zero vote here i have no
suspicion i'm gonna vote for ricky
uh because he's an outlier here and uh
if we group all those people together
well the only two that can be voted for
or if everyone is telling the truth
are ricky and omar they're the only two
have not been verified right now
alana and alana and eli stay with me the
whole time we travel in a trio please
okay what about a quattro [ __ ] it didn't
work
he sons of [ __ ] he sons of [ __ ] no
no he could be dead he could be the
right one
[Music]
no we didn't vote him out bro we didn't
[ __ ] vote him out um
okay what am i i need to go to hang on
hang on
to the reactor can we do that lads
i'll follow you andy unless this is like
a hectic like
insane play he's just trying to kill off
eli and i
i wanna wait i want my [ __ ] so far we
have to go back to the launch pad andy
what are you what's going on
[Music]
oh [ __ ] what up i'm pretty sure ricky
just faked a task
so again i was i'm on team vote for
ricky right now
sorry ricky yeah we went through the y
and he went i'm just very fast they're
doing wires
[Laughter]
sorry
so they only i think they only move when
you complete the last one
hmm
and omar's still alive he he started
following omar after i left i still
think
crew wins here just by finishing tests
so we don't i uh i'm still learning
uh without really any evidence what they
were accused
i thought he got knocked off good luck
everyone have fun
bye-bye oh boy it's either eli omar
it's not eli yeah we'll do
no more oh no nope didn't mean to do
that okay
well okay okay now all right you [ __ ]
shuffle [ __ ]
i got separated real fast huh
but i do have to go to there anyway so
oh it's in here it's in here it's in
here and then you have to go up [ __ ] off
all right come on come on come on come
on come on
in here folly
is on this one okay
they done did that don't i haven't
talked in here yes i have a task in
reactor room this
done
ah okay i have a question so lost on
this map
so anyone know how to buy a beverage
i've bought like nine beverages
you have to buy the one that's in the
picture
um omar is suspicious omar is suspicious
yeah we watched him be scanned it is
definitely not eli okay
um i'm going oma omar yeah
yeah i think it was barley here
well folly could have killed either one
of us oh no he couldn't do it
i was alone with you eli going to
reactor and then i did reactor
he did do it yeah true i did yeah but i
did dip back because i was suspicious of
you
well we were both in the same room
though it would have been hard for folly
to kill us if it's two of us
so that isn't that much of a defense but
um no but eli was with me alone first
and then you showed up
after to get the reactor done so no we
went through the whole like
decontamination change or change right
next to the first
and that was the one that went through
the first which is what blocked you out
yeah listen
i i'm gonna skip vote but i'm pretty
sure you guys ready to vote for someone
i'm just skipping voting because like
there's only a few more tasks left and
if we get it wrong here we get we give
the imposters
that is true but i've already voted so
a good point but i've done more one
[Music]
so i didn't even know how to act normal
like i was just like i don't even know
where a task
is on this yeah i don't know the body
scans
you had you had proof for every single
person the first round
yeah yeah
yeah i didn't know what to do there
because like i didn't know the layout of
the map or anything so like when i
tried when i killed i think it was bruce
i was like i don't even know where to go
and like i popped out of a vent that was
right next to his body and i'm like well
[ __ ]
uh uh we can just hit play again and not
have to worry about hiding the code
right because we're full
yeah before bro we're not poor yet
we're not gonna
the way they get around that though is
if bruce is the last person to hit play
again
no one else can get it okay oh
interesting
so then you guys should be hitting play
again as fast as you can okay yeah yeah
got it
[Music]
okay i can do that
yeah lawrence uh
okay i'm gonna do [ __ ] launch pad
again
brilliant now what uh something over
here i don't know if i've done this
before what is this
oh just refueling pretty basic
[ __ ] uh
okay reactor no
wait is one of them they're already
dealt with that damn all right
[ __ ] i'm gonna go reactor
while we wait on thus launch pad i will
go to
the reactor okay is that eli being
confirmed again
yep already
andy andy andy what are you doing andy
andy what are you doing oh bruce
oh bruce andy andy i need you okay
you gotta help me
okay still gotta do this little reactive
boy down here
pretty worried about being sniped
good yep good stuff all right
um we could go
is it med bay that that's telling me
oh my god okay two of them
the moment the moment the first sabotage
happened bruce and i were right next to
the hand scanners
and almost like in a movie we moved
in sync walking up to it and placed our
hands on it in time
i just did one with bruce as well
and eli we all did the scan yeah i saw
eli again
i found a body inside the right
laboratory room and i saw bruce walking
down
from decontamination what gets me about
about
bruce is that from what i saw the
reactor area was
exclusively me andy and bruce i was in a
room
and then suddenly andy is dead please
don't do it i promise it's very
suspicious
i have been in the reactor the entire
game doing the the rendering
right yeah
again you can do that he did and he did
do it quickly but again i
definitely i'm not you know that someone
else could have snuck in there but
definitely the only people i was in with
were andy and bruce
but be suspicious of bruce i think
that's fair i think that's fair
i'm gonna throw a chip in for ricky too
he walked into a room pretending to do
something and then just stood there
well eli is definitely 100 percent
cleared did someone see
phone calls from your mom or something
did lawrence get scanned as well
i did lawrence okay can you vouch for
lawrence and addiction there
okay um
but eli can verify us both so that i'm
joking
there's some birth [ __ ] there's some
[ __ ] going on here
um
okay i need to go to
well let's go balcony
is this balcony yes yes
i wish somebody could see me doing this
then i would be completed
all right ricky all right uh
it's what is this um why is and why is
it blaring like wait
oh because is that because it's the
second half of task i already started
bruce
bruce i'm not confident i just think he
was the only one who was there
near andy when i was there
okay cool john why
why why are you on my dick john
okay gotta go to admin
john john
i'm going to die get the [ __ ] away from
me john smith
you suspicious [ __ ]
oh my god are you kidding
this is [ __ ] up john what the [ __ ] are
you doing jon
oh no the lights oh ricky just came out
of the bed
[ __ ] oh that was [ __ ]
oh my god
that was real rude oh
jeez wait
so john and ricky it's got to be john
and ricky
john self-reported okay i finished all
my tasks and i was following alana the
whole time
and then the moment i walked away from
her
i found dixon's body in the other room
but there was like
10 seconds between me leaving alana and
finding dixon's body and alana is dead
so well if they're both dead and you
were last seen with both
i mean is that a self-reporter john
that's a little weird
farley what was the lesson that just
said that
i wasn't harley just said that but um i
was doing the weather balloons down in
the bottom right of cafeteria it's
harley and lawrence
um it doesn't take a good rig to run two
streams simultaneously
nah it's super easy
it's lawrence and someone else i'm sorry
johnny
i've already cleared lawrence all right
see you in the afterlife
oh ricky is that your teammate oh you
want to vote for your teammate here
uh the game i'm frozen the game mike's
fans frozen i just unmuted because i
finally figured that it was actually
frozen i'm in a black guy
it looks like a dimmed screen and it
says fixed light zero percent non-stop
oh that's not good hmm i think it's
ricky
i mean you might as well kick me i i
[ __ ] my game's frozen i can't even do
it
who voted who here well i mean i voted
for lawrence but i know everyone else
is out of gg the game's over right is
ricky impossible ricky are you imposter
no my game's broke it's been like five
minutes
it's lawrence
[Laughter]
it's 100 it's not lawrence they still
have to get ricky right
thank you eli and lawrence appreciate it
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] john listen listen my
game is actually
it was actually frozen though i believe
you there but why the [ __ ] are you
hacking and getting imposter every round
ricky how are you doing
dude john look look i'm not even kidding
you could go back to in my
in my stream don't understand i said i
don't want to be
imposter i've never played this map i
cannot win i was so frustrated that i
was imposter again i was like please no
john what the [ __ ] were you doing why
were you chasing me around a table
i was done with masks so you just chased
me around the table it was the most
suspicious [ __ ] i'd ever seen and then
ricky [ __ ] with one oh my i can't
believe that wasn't you
john literally does that all the time i
was like i'm being chased
but then ricky [ __ ] jumped out of a
vent and killed me while i was running
away from john
oh my god bruce had i cleared myself
until i told you
holy [ __ ] when i'm done with tasks i
will then
latch on to someone yeah same here yeah
but
that's threatening start
no i forgot listen i don't have a very
good memory
did everybody click play again hang on
hang on
no i haven't i haven't had
i can't believe alana didn't uh
emergency meeting because i
like messed up and vented right next to
him so i wasn't sure how to
uh i thought that i had to like come
back in i'm back
[Music]
how do i emergency meeting how does how
do you do that uh
there's a the button um it's a big red
button
it's in the is it the office or admin or
cafe that's what i thought is that you
have
to you have to go to a room to do it
right yeah this level it's in cafeteria
on the
bottom right
i cannot [ __ ] believe john smith
trapped me in a room where someone
jumped out of a [ __ ] vent and i got
killed
like are you [ __ ] me
that is ridiculous holy [ __ ]
oh it's done okay uh do i have anything
here yes i do have two tasks in reactor
actually
what's that
what what
[ __ ] now i've forgotten
[ __ ] okay
i also need to do this so let's do it
because it's easy where is where is this
this wooden thing in here this thing
here it's gonna be this gonna be this
cool i'm good here let's [ __ ] get out
all right okay feeling good about things
feeling okay feeling alive and well you
know what i'm saying
let's do this
[ __ ] off lawrence
hmm i feel like everybody's alive
which is very strange what's going on up
there
huh addiction what are you what are you
all doing everybody's hanging out having
a good time oh daddy the other one
finally
that took a while hear me now i'll go
ahead
i was going into that room with the
doors that opened and closed
i was in the middle room omar was coming
towards me
the door closed and i was like i'm gonna
wait for omar
so that the door opens and we're
together and then i went
he wasn't there when it opened again
addiction was there
and then i go up into the reactor room
and omar is there
standing at the reactor he took a vent
up to that room omar's dead and why is
he dead
[Music]
yeah i voted for john john you're good i
don't i'm dead
i don't think that makes it john that's
too elaborate no
someone who's guilty wouldn't come up
with that [ __ ] the boats coming in
the game must have glitched or something
because the door literally closed on
omar
to not be him thinking he's telling the
truth i do not think that makes sean
guilty
but it's a better goose we're throwing
for the crewmates
oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] up
it was a great monologue i was preparing
it the whole time
yeah he says written down on an ipad
cancel culture you guys a guy
oh man i don't think he did anything uh
okay admin it's gonna be admin we're
gonna go
to admin
doing some creepy [ __ ] i'm gonna die
no he left okay eli
eli watch yourself are we playing table
games again bro
you gonna you gonna [ __ ] off you're
gonna leave i hate this table [ __ ] bro
get out of here
why aren't you moving why aren't you
what the [ __ ] is the plan eli lawrence
please help
i'm scared to be like i'm real scared of
you like
[Music]
okay that's good that's good all right
that was [ __ ] shady
nobody tell me that wasn't shady uh is
it in here
ricky did you not look at omar and omar
do it yeah ricky
eli what the [ __ ] were you seriously eli
what were you just doing
why were you just waiting i was just
waiting because i was wondering what you
were doing
well i was like if i get killed i'm
stuck in this room behind this why
aren't you going to clear the thing if
you just go directly up i was just stuck
in there
i was i was
what eli down south where the uh button
is what are you talking about
i just came down right and i walk over
to where you came from and i see a dead
body
uh no that's not okay what do you mean
no
he obviously he just murdered him
there's
absolutely no [ __ ] way that i would
be impostor three
times it is it is possible i believe it
is but i am
very suspicious of what you were just
seeing me like hold on
what the [ __ ] were you doing i was
looking at my chat okay i was talking to
my channel
why are you yeah because originally you
told me you were sussing me out and now
it's he's talking to his chat
i was talking about i walked down there
yeah
no no no he like cornered me in a room
and just stood there
i did not kill you i could have killed
you when you walked down nobody else was
there
no there were two people there that's
why i left no you
you left after them right i was also
behind you i could have killed you i did
not i walked down into the cafeteria
you could have had to walk away from my
dead body it was a true it was
a self claim on the body i'm telling you
guys you guys are being played by ricky
i could be in the popular vote and not
get ostracized by my peers you guys are
being
played by ricky we might be but i i do
buy his logic who do i vote for who am i
ricky ricky please ricky ricky hasn't
even told us what his last task was
oh [ __ ] no you guys this is bad
ricky's last task he never said what he
was doing he just pointed
you you actually did not lay the task
out
this is not gonna be good for us
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] off eli get away from me
eli
okay i have to do med bay
yup i keep pressing up my accent
i think he is right that when we walk
down the car at all
do i have one in reactos so let's go
there anyway
but then med base like right here in it
oh if i have someone watch me get
scanned addiction
please observe thank you thank you thank
you thank you thank you
my name is
then i need to go to the lab
i hope eli is not [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
what are you what are you [ __ ] doing
okay that's that's good that's good for
me i love a lock school
i hope they're goes to doing their tasks
but to be fair when i'm ghost i don't
always do tasks so what do i do now just
like hide maybe
just like stay here forever or what
i do like the one where there's the
table so they can't get to me because i
can just walk around the table
[Music]
oh
thank you for keeping me alive there
wait so who was it who was it i'm gonna
remake the lobby
and andy damn [ __ ] freaky
so
bruce i swear to god i was so livid at
the beginning of that game when i was
muted i was just like
i there's no way i can even play this
right now did you do the other map
chad how am i supposed to kill eli
everybody's grouped up bro there's no
way i could do that
so you but all you both just needed to
kill one person there and it would have
ended
so we finished that task right that's
what happened i did kill somebody
yeah i was zooming around the vents
trying to find anyone that was like not
next to someone
i killed the lawrence i think new code
coming in he's live
definitely live somebody in the final
second
here comes a new code right now gotcha
when i tried to get people to believe it
was eli i was like what well no
again that happened because he was
because of the weird table situation
that was happening with me
which also happened with john who also
wasn't the bad guy if i wanted to kill
you i would have gone
into that room and killed you invented
right then yeah but i could
i could walk around the table that's the
point you can avoid it chat chat
chat chat you don't chat i voting for
ricky is a smart
call because it makes me look like not
guilty if i'm voting for a killer
but it just so happened that everybody
voted for eli as well so
it with [ __ ] that's like i can't believe
they all voted for eli
yeah what yeah it was a solid reversal
of
god damn nobody except bruce here knows
me
so you guys will you guys will come hold
on hold on i'm sorry eli i'm so sorry
i just want to remind everyone that
goodbye john did you just say i'm
paranoid
the chat just say i'm paranoid are you
stupid of course i'm paranoid that's the
[ __ ] point of the game what do you
mean
i'm paranoid yeah that's the whole video
game
you're supposed to be um
okay where are we going uh this is
oh my god what the [ __ ]
i thought omar do it oh well okay
quick yeah it looked like it was uh i
walked right by the body and
i was trying not to sneeze at the time
so it's either omar pretty sure
i'm pretty sure it's del mar someone
voted on a one yeah omar what are you
how did you have
trying not to sneeze yeah like in real
life
no no defense in game with defenses i'm
just i was walking
the other direction i don't know yeah
like i'm trying to again i'm trying to
learn these moves these maps
i saw the body go down so i got i walk
around with the map
up and i get caught on all the [ __ ]
geometry
is there is there any like can anyone
verify bruce or
i mean no no no we don't have to vote
you don't have to vote but i mean it's
going to be omar he'll kill you
if someone says they saw someone kill
someone or not
i didn't see the body so i was on the
far
right i think farley was with me um and
i
was doing the satellite [ __ ] where
you have to find the planet and it takes
me way too long
the telescope yep yeah i didn't even do
this
[Music]
okay what do we have to do here i have
to go to the room next to office
not in office but room next to office
this is too many people you guys are too
many [ __ ] people somebody's gonna die
somebody's gonna die somebody's gonna
die
i don't like stacks
okay that's too slow it's middling
i just said you know i just kept saying
somebody's gonna [ __ ] die
hey guys i don't know how hey what's up
hello oh we got you
locked doors uh
under sabotage there's like a an icon
under each room okay so i don't know
where that body is because the lights
are off john you're dead
wait what oh i'm fine
you can't see the body but the goddamn
button lights up yes
so when you walk by at the report button
lights up and that's why i reported
again i don't know what the body is i do
know that i'm in the bottom middle i
think it's the admin office
i've never known anyone to be able to
like to be that quick on the report
button just because it pops up though
you can spam it i've seen it happen i've
seen it
you happen so far bruce yeah you're
right it is these two bodies i found but
if you've helped me off you're gonna die
so there's
more i can vouch for two people i was
with so
it's between you lawrence ricky and
dixon there well
so i i think i was prediction fixing the
lights i was with
lawrence we aren't meeting automatically
we have to do it manually
yes and then leave and then report so
can you can you kill on the report
immediately or is there okay
also lawrence uh you would see the bar
go up if who said they were with me
fixing the light because no one was with
me
addiction i was with you fixing the
lights i didn't see it i know the
visibility was low but i was
fine it's not pushing you manually
overlay was probably over it then okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
would have seen him dixon would have
seen him because no because he had the
overlay up and i was flicking the
switches so i didn't
think it was there i was i was stephen
what is pka i don't know what that is
i'm skipping but again the only person
near that body that i saw was lawrence
that's right he's right you boys right
yeah i guess so
i haven't really seen anyone else's type
in bruce either so yeah
bruce is right i think lawrence also
defended omar
in that kill if i'm not mistaken
[Music]
i don't recall defending anybody but
maybe i did i don't know
um who who's the other who killed y'all
uh omar killed me and then got voted out
i got very caught by bruce he was got it
lawrence killed me
yeah bruce is playing [ __ ] well this
game real well he's like fully on top of
everything
he literally saw omar yeah but he's also
right about lawrence
oh my game froze
oh the longest is not responding oh no
fix itself
just out here doing tasks you know
hoping they figure it out hoping
everyone gets what they need
[Music]
what you eating john jalapeno
uh kettle chips nice you hear me i'm not
even eating any right now no i could
just tell like
by the way you were talking that you
were eating
all right i found bruce's body
oh bruce wow and farley was
chasing me it's not fun right before no
right now
i found it he turned around and went
another way
it's not barley not me it's not friendly
why
is everyone so defensive of farley
because we vouch for him we can voucher
him
because i was with him a lot of the time
and i thought he was going to [ __ ]
kill me at security cams or not security
cams the one where
i clicked the two big screens and then
yeah whatever the [ __ ]
so did you know that that was an upload
andy because you were faking doing it if
not
i'll be honest with you farley i have a
really really bad short-term memory and
that is that's why i'm not very good at
this game
okay let's take a look that part is true
he's bad at this game please
please stay with me let's travel in a
trio i welcome it please okay i mean we
were just with him right we were just
with him
yeah but if he doesn't know what that
task was that was the last thing he did
i have such a bad memory i'm really
really bad at this [ __ ] character
it's
i don't know who to vote for though the
last task you did lawrence
so to listen to bruce you should have
listened to bruce
hangs off the tree with the little first
strikers they go like okay addiction
what was the last task you did
uh i was on the opposite with the far
right side i think it was i was the
leaves and then i had to go to the
opposite side
in the desalination room to do uh
communications i believe is that what
the room is
the very bottom i was in the very bottom
left and i was going to the verge it was
really smart of lawrence
you were doing i was running and then
farley was after
that orange is just silent you were
doing there was no chance he even said
anything and then just like
what was the last task
hmm last thing i did was a tesla maybe
there's one imposter
or
well this is so easy i called him out
around before and then he killed you
straight away and i was like why and
then he didn't even say anything that
entire deliberation
and nobody accused him of anything this
is the easiest thing in the world
god damn lawrence i mean i think maybe
we should shorten deliberation time
because
they deliberated and then eli one by one
was like
what were you doing what were you doing
is that bad like i don't know it seems
what is this needs to be both
you blew it man i called out lawrence
around before you killed me come on eli
i don't recall oh i have goldfish
too that is not true eli you are too
good at this game yeah i play this game
i've played this game but i'd still have
goldfish memory
oh ricky watch the [ __ ] out lawrence is
on yes
so it's just it's just lauren it's just
learned the other one was omar was the
first killer i i
called it out yeah i know i know i know
i know i know you call it omar but
yeah bruce you were 100 right to believe
his excuse you know
why i don't i i don't know people here
yet i'm going to give them the benefit
of the doubt
i know that you could lie
i'm dead how is the game not over
if lawrence wants holy [ __ ]
oh oh maybe one more person no one more
yeah dude
everyone i was literally running i was
running to hit the emergency meeting
button when lawrence got me
son of a yes skit you guys
oh i think it's mine um there's just no
guarantee that you uh that you were
right
uh do quit first do it quick before
paulie right i'm trying i'm trying
[Music]
oh my god just in time oh my god
there were literally two people left
holy [ __ ] i was
i was calling out the killers from the
very beginning
it just doesn't there's no guarantee you
were right you know
[Music]
are you out of your mind why would you
defend yourself unless you're guilty
did you see those two bodies on the left
asking me about tasks it would have been
up i've never done that
yeah you just didn't reply i was like
they didn't even impress him but time
ran out so i just voted for you
yeah yes i had laura i don't know if
lawrence or whoever
locked that door when i was following
with farley i was like i'm [ __ ] i'm
dead here dude
i was locking yours i was trying to keep
people i was trying to separate people
so lawrence could get someone
yeah lawrence you were like creeping
around me and i don't think your kill
button was ready yet so i
started running to the emergency meeting
button and then you caught i got hooked
on like a corner and you got
dude that's the worst with me like like
omar said earlier i get caught on geo
all the time in this [ __ ] game i
always like
the ping doesn't help either you guys
just gotta get good man you just gotta
get good bring up my map
also i need to pee after this round okay
so let's
all right all right all right all right
all right all right all right okay now
ladies
what are you doing john okay he's doing
task
oh this one sucks
somebody
it's that thank you [ __ ]
okay i still need to go down the bottom
and i'm really scared that i'm gonna die
was it inside it is outside
okay let's go up around weapons
oh my gosh hey emma
hey what are you doing down there bro oh
[ __ ] what the [ __ ]
everybody's [ __ ] dead i walked
i walked into a room that omar was
walking out of
so here's what happened i found the body
and i don't know eli i don't know who
the body was next to me because there
was somebody next to me
with the dead body yeah the dead body
was farley i did see
omar head down that way but i also saw a
name as well that
wasn't yours are you all oh wait so eli
is also in your
who is in that room so i walked in hit
the report button
it came up that bruce reported it before
i did the two dead bodies are right next
to each other
okay omar was leaving the room so
i'm willing to believe it's omar because
was walking down there
and then you said he left the room right
he was leaving the room did not report
them
while i walked in met bruce two dead
bodies on the floor
i'm convinced it could be omar but when
i
left the room farley was on the far left
side where apparently his body was found
and john smith was walking in from the
bottom as i was exiting from the bottom
again okay omar why didn't you report
those two dead bodies that were right
next to each other
dead bodies how did you not see those
two dead bodies on the floor of the room
in the room i didn't go in that room i
was trying to find my way
around that map wait i have a quick
question to figure out if it's lawrence
or not lawrence what task did you do
this time
just pouring fuel into something i got
fuel from the shed
[Laughter]
uh andy john and lawrence and omar have
to vote so
i guess yeah okay i don't know who to
vote for but i said my piece about john
he was walking in that
area while i mean i don't know i thought
i didn't want
to walk down there this stuff happened
so i'm just gonna
how are they both killed in the same
room like that too damn you serious
okay all right just be suspicious
all i'm saying is oh my god follow me if
you want dude
okay andy okay
um all right i didn't see [ __ ]
but i i think bruce is safe there
what are you two am i being chased by
you now emma is that what's [ __ ]
happening here
huh huh we can go do this
it's gonna be up here
did it okay great love to see it
oh boy you know just trying to survive
out here is a little
little bean you know trying to live my
[ __ ] life
and not get killed by probably omar
maybe bruce not sure
i love that one it's so easy great jon
what a [ __ ]
okay all right so guys alana was on omar
last time and alana is dead
though i think his teammate killed there
oh eli i totally believe you but i'm
still voting for omar because
i was we were right next to the body
last time all right
i just want to get over here i just
wanted to get myself seen
i was ricky for a bit and i saw lawrence
for a bit yeah i walked into the room
where the body was the other one could
be learned
for me i was doing little test tubes
yeah i was with you if it's okay are we
voting for omar i
missed playing omar but you could first
i'm getting screwed here because
i was i was right next to eli when he
reported the body i didn't see anybody i
was just heading into that room i didn't
see anybody else either
i walked into how did joan get out of it
i was reported right
i went over to do electrical or do they
not report my body ricky was
taking a bit to do his task but then we
walked back
and then the body was there so i don't
think ricky did that there
but again again alana was killed
and she was on omar last round that's
important
i still think it is vengeance i skipped
because i
this could be a galaxy brain play by
bruce or eli
[Music]
else if a third wants to follow us i
hope that's right please hope it was
online
and whoever doesn't you're a [ __ ]
killer dude
that's something an imposter would say
come with us
oh [ __ ] what up what's up we're ghosts
was it you omar
i was one of them yes okay guys so you
did walk out of that [ __ ] room
how did you both get killed right next
to each other
he john john killed me okay i got killed
by john
homer addiction walked into the room at
the same time and then addiction was
dead
damn no one's suspecting jon right now
but the good call on the other player
good because he's being extra quiet
during the meetings is what he does
so uh i don't know how to do this talk
too good at this um
too good at this game with this crew of
people so
guys i'm in the specimen room and i have
to do a task that it's like a bunch of
numbers
oh oh yeah i can count yeah there you go
apparently i caught apparently oppressed
one wrong
five six seven eight nine ten
beautiful we did it
i'm done i'm out of time
i'm gonna pretend i'm this snowman right
here
if they if they can set this one up for
a double kill
oh no nevermind yeah just down john
can i help with this i don't i don't
think i can right now no
if it's an emergency thing we can't do
anything we have to do it got it
all right
yeah [ __ ] nobody's suspecting john
this is i don't even know if he's gonna
get suspected what's gonna happen
no it's down here oh your gerbils down
here in o2 still
yeah oh no john did
all right who was with who it was john
it was totally john
because i was with lawrence and uh he
killed the body right in front of me
okay yeah cause you were just with andy
so i believe yeah he killed andy right
in front of me
again if lauren killed andy right in
front of me
i was with lawrence too late it's not
gonna work john you're too [ __ ] late
on that exactly
i'll
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
what did i say earlier if john is being
extra quiet during meetings he's
probably in a box
[Music]
earlier yeah i could do that too click
play again click play again okay i got
it yeah i click playground bathroom
i guess they want us he wants us in the
lobby that was a
that was a clear-cut uh beef
i beefed it i was looking at vitals i
saw a little bit
like green's color show up as dead and i
went over to the emergency meeting
the door opened and had lawrence and
somebody else walked right in front of
john
he killed something he got andy if i had
my wits about me i would have reported
it faster
i was like i got to make a break for
because i thought he was going to kill
me but i forgot about the cooldown
yeah the cooldown timer yeah it's it's
not quite like guess who
or you know prop hunt but it's similar
these new maps are throwing me for a
loop i was doing good as the bad guy on
that
the og map but these new ones i can't
figure it out
you'll get the hang of it and then
you'll be a killing machine
machine i think i like this one best as
imposter
just because of the um the seismic
you can so easily isolate somebody on
that or get it like a double kill that
way it's also a double-edged sword as
well
yeah you get too many people what's the
size make is is one of the
one of the prices yeah yeah
does that one have a timer on it does it
like
or is it one that just makes it annoying
like the lights it's a minute it's a
minute and then if it goes
off uh the imposters win
it's like the o2 or reactor and the
first map
yeah i like how the cameras on this one
you have to switch through them instead
of seeing all four at the same time
all right we back we're back is
everybody everybody back everybody
i am man good to go
uh let me make sure that everybody we
got alana and omar
ricky we're just waiting for addiction
to pinch off that loafer oh
okay i'm gonna grab some water
while i wait no worries
i probably got time for like two more i
know i'm the worst
good bathroom break
all right cowboy cowboy starting like
right now man come on baby
the niners lost of course they did so
many penalties
couldn't convert on third down either
whack everybody back everybody back
silver lawrence
uh lawrence you there
ah yeah he is he just doesn't want to
talk to you right now
are you ever all just like are you ever
all just paying attention to your
regular life maybe you're going to the
restroom maybe you're on your phone
you're like am i the imposter
[Laughter]
every day of my life because even even
right now i'm like i hope they know i'm
not the imposter
i was looking at the vent in my bathroom
like how do i squeeze
i'm never literally never the imposter
but apparently if i defend myself i'm
guilty yeah that's super suspicious bro
so anybody in the legal system if they
did bruce
you could call a meeting you're like
first of all i didn't do it
i never i never
yeah i'm here yo let's go let's go
i may have revealed the room code in
part excellent
yeah we'll roll the dice on this one
all right we're not guilty love that for
us
ricky's probably pretty chill too oh go
roberto would do that get ready to toss
back up
okay shall we go to like communications
or some [ __ ] like that sounds so cool
right
john left the game
why are they leaving
connector left the gamers yo what's up
what's happening is everyone leaving the
game
all f4 brings up the map
hey guys uh good news everyone we won so
that's tight
i'm pretty happy because i was imposter
and i knew i was gonna ruin it for
[Laughter]
i was closing out andy resource monitor
and i like clicked on among us and then
closed out
[Laughter]
cowboys or rams all right so that was an
impossible
job yeah no no victory it says it says
it says create pictures
no but on the cowboys the beginning of
the season they're always better at the
beginning of the season um okay so
canceling bet on rams betting on that
got it
new code code is coming into chat right
now
bang there it is oh god you know that
feeling when like you just
i don't know you just [ __ ] up that's a
feeling where your body gets really
really hot and i closed out of the game
i was like oh god
oh i thought john left first omar of
being the imposter when he was 100
percent dead so i
i know how you feel yeah you sure did
she's so dead crawdaddy
uh blames himself he says don't [ __ ]
this up andy right before i did
so what did you accidentally click leave
game
no no on the on the windows task bar i
was trying to close out on my nzxt
like uh resource monitor and i right
clicked among us instead and then just
immediately close windows
he was trying to turn ray tracing on for
the game yeah
gotta trace this race bro make it look
real pretty
i'm so excited
i didn't click the image away fast
enough but just so you guys know uh
i am an imposter and i
don't [ __ ] feel good about it so i'm
gonna go kill myself is what i'm gonna
do
who's the best person to kill like bruce
is smart
um so i feel like he's a he's a good
person to kill quickly
not really so worried about john you
know
not super concerned i guess and just
keep on moving
that was a good clean kill you guys that
was a good clean kill and he's smart too
was that eli
hold up where's my mask on here we go
okay
well i guess i have a toss literally
well that's odd what's happening john
john just cruised right past a dead body
um wait what just now dude like you guys
john give us a give us a really
long-winded speech about why
absolutely not john or lawrence they
were around me for a lot of the time
yeah um uh and yeah i mean i guess i did
walk by that dead body but i was with
you
all of the time leading up yeah i don't
i don't actually suspect john i just
thought it was funny to see you
okay it's my first like 10 games i would
miss everybody i walk by
one time i missed someone being killed
in the same room as me
yeah i didn't even realize cat is so
quick to point out how blind we are when
someone dies
yeah it's not good you can also see the
report thing that pops up too if you're
near the body like
i know you guys don't believe me but uh
yeah
i'm sure
we can we can rule out i guess
collectively the power of threes
john i and uh i guess eli all agree that
we are
well uh
i saw john and lawrence for a lot of
that round and alana was coming from
right to left to do like i was going up
to fix the thing
but you guys had already done it so i
was heading to the top to
do the task [ __ ] and you guys had
already done it you'll come back and
didn't kill me on right side
or whatever i don't know i thought
really hard about it
i'm skipping i'm scared i guess so also
skip okay
maybe we can compare notes john let's go
make
we're the three amigas make a little
trio
all right
one's not looking good it's not looking
gravy you guys
this isn't uh i don't think this is
gonna go well for us at all
because we've got that trio that are
gonna be hard to separate uh
let's just go anywhere i guess
i don't use my sabotage very often you
know
i don't know why bruce paired himself
with me like i don't feel like that was
the right call to make
okay okay
somebody somebody in the stack got
murdered i saw
four people somebody in the stack up
mode on top of that seismic
bruce literally chased me the entire
time and i
juked him but he was chasing me that is
not true at all john i followed you
to make sure you knew i wasn't the
killer and then it was almost
okay so who was in that stack just then
there was a lot of people i was just
telling you like that's a lot of people
trying to do one task bro
was it all of us i think it was wait a
person i was at the very bottom i was
getting desalinated in the in the shower
see that john didn't even know there was
a death there
that is a bit weird john i still think
john is not the killer despite
all of those things it's not john or
lawrence i think it might be bruce
i think it might okay i think how bad i
am at this game
proves how innocent i am that's not a
good defense
with i think it was me john lawrence
and 90 other people it feels like it was
[ __ ] all of us it might have been
everyone except for addiction
yeah i was at the bottom of my little
hamstrings i wasn't there either i saw
you all right
so i ran to the top left one to complete
that alert
no it's john i literally ran your circle
and bruce ran in a circle with me
because
i did no i wasn't chasing you i wanted
to make sure you knew i was to be fair
i did that i did call you out for that
exact same thing a round ago john and
you
weren't trying to kill me
don't it is not john it is not john it's
okay under lauren
i think it's bruce and andy i think it's
bruce and alana um
that sounds like deflection and he's
trying to throw us
i'm voting twice for you hey it's not
andy 100
is bro i don't know what to do i don't
know
all right well good luck everybody
there's not it wasn't [ __ ] that we could
do
that was it was a good kill my kill was
[ __ ] dope there
bruce needs to [ __ ] up his game you
son of a [ __ ]
but i don't know that we can do anything
about any of this
is what i'm saying
i really hope bruce has someone
did you guys all to stack over to the
other one again [ __ ] hell man
all right
lawrence is alone but he sees me let's
go
i guess into storage oh what's he even
gonna do you know you know what i'm
saying
why are you [ __ ] chasing me bro why
are you chasing me bro the [ __ ] your
problem
[ __ ] your problem
what are you gonna do son of a [ __ ]
cool yeah definitely did that task
why was he just staring at me like what
was the
[Music]
out plan we gotta [ __ ] kill somebody
fam
uh if i did storage in theory i can't i
can't [ __ ] with any of these dudes hang
on hang on i'm gonna go
let's go this way lawrence is just like
keeping an eye out for me
but what's he got like what's he gonna
do with just staring at me like i'm not
gonna [ __ ] kill you why are you
creeping on me it's so
weird oh i should have killed him now
you would have seen it
but he's just like well you don't [ __ ]
well you don't [ __ ] like what am i
gonna do with that information lawrence
he would have seen me just not do a task
then though so let's just
kill him keep running
okay whatever one of you will [ __ ]
get that
i'm just gonna walk away from the body
so that i
appear to be nowhere dear lord just died
all right okay oh [ __ ]
okay everybody's [ __ ] dead and andy
it is alana it is absolutely not me it
is me
john and i have been together the whole
[ __ ] time it has to be alana i have
seen you together the whole time so then
security camera room oh so then what
happened to lawrence if you guys were
together the whole time
he's dead yeah how did lawrence die is
my question
you killed him you killed him
okay cool all right i guess i'll just be
voted for oh that's cool
by what logic what have i done
you haven't been seen and it's me and
john together the whole time
yeah i mean i've seen you guys i've seen
you guys plenty i have seen you guys
plenty there's no [ __ ] way you
haven't seen me
i've absolutely passed you guys a bunch
of [ __ ] times i did the scan thing
when you all went to the left one i was
like well
you don't trust me so you're all going
to the left i did the one in the [ __ ]
middle
you saw me do that because i was the one
who scared my hand
we already voted you're ready you're
already voted for lauren i guess i am
skip vote i'm a vote for addiction
because he's also been by himself though
all right you can go [ __ ] yourselves
that's fair it's diction
i did kill a lot of people though um so
[Laughter]
i did clean up a lot of people i
feel good about my ktd there
why didn't you guys get bruce
john because you just shouted it was
bruce yeah there wasn't any logic i
don't think
you don't have any reasons laurence you
made yourself like
you were so weird that you just kept
staring at me you just kept waiting and
staring at me from around the corner i
was like what are you doing
because if i'm seen with you and then i
die it's a dead giveaway that you're the
killer which is what happened
who's the they didn't suspect that
though because nobody saw you with me
it wasn't it
four stack kill because all there are
there were four of us and i was curious
to see who
oh i got the i got the kill i got the
four stack it was very satisfying
is chat the only one complaining about
stacking or or
do you get oh yeah yeah literally
everything in this yeah no i i think
that
you need to be more safely than us but i
mean right
i think you need to have the stat kills
because sometimes if people group
together on top of each other there's no
other option
yeah i just mean like sticking together
because when i finish my task i stayed
with
the issue with it because honestly if
you get away with it that's awesome
it's funny i don't know i don't
understand yeah kind of
all on top of each gameplay i did the
full stack bruce definitely killed me on
that one
you were oh killer yeah did we wait
john doesn't know what he's doing maybe
we press at the same time that's why
you're
chasing me you're trying to kill me i
actually was not going to kill you john
i was actually going to leave you to the
very end because you were the one that
suspected me
um
that was a blast guys thank y'all for
having me oh wait did we get a double
kill on the stack is that what happened
i don't know we'll have to watch it back
yeah man hi andy thanks for playing good
hearing
love y'all miss y'all oh yeah maybe we
did alana i didn't know that you did it
too
i definitely clicked it i don't know if
it happened you guys did one of those
what was that one game
uh splinter cell like one of the newer
ones where you get where you tag teamed
like
headshotted with your co-op
it wasn't exactly the same wait wait it
was a double kill
yeah i died on it and somebody else did
oh [ __ ] beautiful walk
that is that's awesome yeah i can't
believe it was you bruce
anyway i [ __ ] hate it and i hate
being the imposter and it makes me want
to die even though i did clean some [ __ ]
son of a [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
cool i am shaking
let's just you know just [ __ ] go down
here or whatever see what happens never
use fence because that's how you [ __ ]
get caught
you know maybe someone will have a task
over here seriously what was laurence's
strat
it was so weird okay let's wait for
someone to walk into this room maybe
like how likely is that i know there are
two tasks in here that people
tend to enjoy doing
right right you guys right
nope new
okay we'll take that and we'll leave
oh laurence definitely just saw me walk
out of here
[ __ ] that's not good that's none of
that's good
he hasn't seen him though okay
okay
kill count of hands [ __ ] can't do
[ __ ] to bruce could have killed him
could have killed him
but he left this is like not a good way
to go actually let's not go that way and
kill someone else i can kill someone
else
where are you [ __ ] at they still
haven't found that body jesus
just wait a bit you know just like give
it a couple of seconds see if anyone
else shows up here
you feel me
there we go
i could i could have killed folly that
would have [ __ ] risk though
i should have i should have eli what you
doing are you killing people too what's
what's happening
uh i don't know [ __ ]
i hate it so much oh finally
all right bottom left okay goodness i
was also bottom left just highly good
why is farley grayed up but not exed out
it's probably a glitch
he was muted yeah he was dancing the
door where he's freaking me out so i
think he was having a shoes or
something
[Music]
john did anyone come from that area did
you see him no it was just
omar was with us for a little bit yeah i
was running with you too because
what i was i was running away from
farley almost the entire time
but then i saw you two together and him
not killing you so i stick stuck with
you
yeah i literally stood there and watched
farley get scanned
well i mean i mean they're dead yeah i
was gonna say are you clearing fire
he's dead well they're not dead they're
they're just not on the server anymore
okay okay is that a ghost
[Laughter]
we have a medium um has anyone else been
scared
so that we can clear anyone else well
you know here's i'm just going to say it
bruce hasn't accused anyone yet
so that's because i don't know oh my god
yeah that's pretty suspicious bruce
john just jumps to me every single time
[Music]
those [ __ ] maze things that you have
to do in the outside
are take way too long amaze things
[Music]
okay
i'm sorry i'm sorry what
so again i didn't see the body i just
clicked report what the [ __ ]
okay cool mind games man
ah boy i [ __ ] hate this so much
just let it be over with you know what
i'm saying just get me the [ __ ] out of
here hold up wait
uh let's just go to electrical or
whatever
because that seems like a location that
will take me 15 seconds to get to you
know what i'm saying
i had around the other night when i was
on the imposter once why is it happening
repeatedly i [ __ ]
hate it oh is everybody up
nowhere great oh oh you could kill john
you could kill jon
okay
again i'm just gonna [ __ ] do this uh
uh oh there's this one
this one i need this one this one this
one whoa what
what what okay we got it okay
i should have killed first just there
okay good now i have to get the [ __ ]
away from here
so nobody realizes what i've done
get out as soon as possible
so nobody knows all my crimes
okay i'll just have to you know we're
just
not on discord you don't have to be oh
[ __ ] what up dixon and i just found a
body inside electrical
uh which wouldn't have been me or him we
walked over from
lab yeah and then i noticed it when it
opened
who did you find no i guess it doesn't
matter i think it's bruce
okay eli addiction do you guys mind if i
pal around with you to maintain my
innocence from now on because i finished
all my tasks i just want to read i
didn't
yeah i mean can i also get on on that i
will say i mean i'm pretty sure that i'm
right
next to electrical and oma's the only
person i've seen
but i'm pretty sure is it the bottom
left then it's the one in omaha that's
it
it's it's definitely not me i was
completely by myself i'm just saying
oma's the only person i think that i've
seen in that area no no no no no
no i wasn't with omar i just saw omar
the body was on the left
if it's the thing that's in the left far
left of the map inside
well i guess we don't know what happened
what was the last task you did i just
connected some
wires in a in a thing and was going to
do he's
he's right because i just saw a lana
yeah okay so i was in that room where
there's like the training for each other
that's right and then omar was horrible
first i'm
down to vote for omar here it's it's not
me
i didn't see him do it i'm just saying
he's the only person in the area that's
needed
to throw breakers to unlock the door
great we just gotta put one of them off
because i said i saw omar near there i'm
being done
that doesn't make any sense i'm voting
i'm not [ __ ] you i'm vouching for
both you i'm voting for you no i'm not
vouching for him i'm saying i saw him
near it
this is getting mad oh my god
[Laughter]
[Music]
that was [ __ ] beautiful work mate
beautiful work there eli
very good
saw a dead body and then left yeah i had
nothing to say
i didn't know who did it
yeah always why very good working lives
respect you
that's circular logic i mean
you reset the kill cooldowns on the
killers though so you have a reset on ah
nobody else can die et cetera et cetera
so floyd if i'm talking too much when
guilty why do i keep succeeding when
guilty
shut up that doesn't make any sense i'm
[ __ ] nailed back already there yeah
yeah
i mean you guys you guys did an
excellent job we did playing off each
other
yeah so happy that was very that was a
good quality
you reported it after i saw it too so i
was worried people would suspect me
because i didn't report no no no no no
yeah wait why were you vouching for eli
there
because we came from no i i don't know
his voice
[Music]
hello i like your party hat
that's a good hat it's a good hat
we had a birthday party oh
birthday uh
that was [ __ ] great game seriously
the person who said i talk too much when
guilty i also talk a lot when i have a
lucid sex
suspect someone but i [ __ ] killed
that bro are you kidding me i killed
that
okay i hate it and i'm still shaking
like i don't know if you can even see
that i can't see what my webcam looks
like but like i
i [ __ ] hate it uh hang on hang on
whoa cool i probably should have been
paying attention rather than talking to
you guys
i deserve that one that's what i'm gonna
say i deserved that that was on me
i was just hanging out there being like
oh let's talk about that last game chat
you [ __ ] get
snipe i don't even know who killed me
come on either because this body i i
walked down and omar came up and this
body was right below the spaceship where
we
started from i went up to the seismic
stabilizers oh you guys saying it's
following people followed me up to the
first one but they
went to the second one i feel like that
seems right but i don't know i saw you
yeah i blamed the guy
he smoked too much wood got it you guys
got the other one
yeah you all saw a blue body thank you
also yes i read both chats
and the person on youtube i stream on
both youtube and twitch before
so the meeting was called kind of
doesn't matter because alana fixed the
electrical and then killed me
last last round so um
activity i used to stream on mixer as
well stabilizers
i feel like i think i think it was
farley ricky and maybe omar
or i saw him walking up but i went up
and i saw
two people at that one already so i went
back to
and then i die immediately because i'm
talking about how much i hate it it's
[ __ ] stupid
so who cleared lawrence by the way i
didn't
here's one thing eli self-reported last
round so
um keep that in mind keep that in mind
i'm just i reported
you self-reported yeah you did yeah last
round yes you did i'm going to go ahead
and uh
remember i was with you and we reported
the body together
either way you're reporting
not from meds
all right let me do some tasky tasks to
make up for the shame that i have
brought upon
these fine people by talking to my chat
and dying
like i was literally just [ __ ]
standing there that's absolutely my bad
i have no excuse for that [ __ ]
back to storage
oh i just have to fuel another engine i
see icse
i'm just out here trying to do a task
[Music]
i can't do anything about the sabotages
so don't at me
so he's going over eli
and eli is dead now i know which which
is really bad because that means he
doesn't actually
he just changes his behavior every game
which makes it really hard to rely on
eli
i'm gonna bring up that he vouched for
me and he's clearly not an imposter
therefore i am clearly not
oh i vouched for you make sense
i don't know that it still applies
though because dixon and lawrence could
be like covering for each other
should be true no
it was just the two of us so that logic
is sound although i will say
it's not me ricky was there where was
everyone
good i was the very very bottom uh
doing the putting the gems in the flower
stuff in the box thing
that sounds made up he made that that's
not right where is that like top right
uh my mighty bush i have done a monkey
with you i did that
yeah it was so from the middle it was
like up and right
almost right when you go in right maybe
you think near admin or something like
that
because like your laboratory i don't
know the map
if i could bring the map up i could tell
you but yeah it's a bummer though i did
not pass anyone i did not see anyone so
yeah there's two people left we have no
idea
who the other one is no one's [ __ ]
accusing folly at all
wait because john calls me on in every
round so i'm going to go ahead and vote
for josh
dixon what did you just do i voted for
john too because
you know what he's not saying anything
i'm going to skip
i mean why i don't okay john just
just called out skip and i'm pretty sure
that means farley's suspect too
okay i feel like it's bruce bruce is
like directing too much antagonism
towards all right good luck
good luck
hello hello hello
so folly killed me who else omar
oh wow
i didn't think it was bruce was 50 right
i don't know why he finally
had to say skip there i think he's he
he was guilty yeah he could have just
stayed quiet yeah and then he barely
said anything
and they weren't suspecting him at all i
mean
you don't have to kill everybody no you
just have to get it
that was risky by farley there but what
was i mean it wasn't
it wasn't john wants an expert i mean
it wasn't john it wasn't me
listen listen bruce i do change up my
game so you cannot rely
on my previous that's bad
what do you mean that's bad i gotta keep
saying
someone in my chat said bruce has
trained himself to always be borderline
suss
i mean it's funny because you guys i
think i'm suss because i talk so i just
want to i know
no don't do that accusations that are
suspects yeah but he's right often he's
awfully correct
you point your finger
previous round when you suspected me and
i ended up dying that
oh wow i hope you're okay that's brutal
i mean it doesn't you have to do that or
else you lose
you don't have a choice he's right bruce
is right maybe there's some dynamic of
this it's brilliant
we're good to go right there's only oh
no one more
i'm dipping in i'm dipping out i'm done
for that
it was all it was this was fun i played
longer than i thought i would
[Music]
miss you omar sorry this is all
distracted from your departure
sorry laura love you buddy bye all right
so should i lower this to
one imposter since there's eight of us
you can try that out
yeah i guess yeah okay as long as it's
not me that sounds pretty good yeah can
you make it so i'm not the imposter
oh first left cool fibers
maybe lower the uh thing down to 20 the
kill timer down to 20. sure yeah i will
do that
kill timer or and or range to see if
that'll help
gotcha all right don't show the code
i'm gonna put it in
do not show the code it is coming in
right now
got it that's my favorite anime
character
nope can't figure out who you'd be
referring to
could be a street fighter reference i
guess
all right uh kill cooldown is at 20
seconds beautiful
okay 20 seconds you want to turn visual
tasks off
so that we can't sort of eliminate
people
if there's only one imposter
yeah that's gonna make the game even
harder but yeah let's do it you wanna i
like it
we could turn up player speed to 1.25
you want to put up one point so just
player speed but not imposter
uh it's not the same it's all the same
like yeah it's gonna be like you just
look out for the slow guy
and then
and confirming it ejections doesn't
really matter either but
you know it's whichever you want to have
it on so there's only one
guys you can't see the game because we
still have the code up the code is still
up
the code is still up we have not started
the game okay i'm not taking the
background off chat stop yelling at me
the code's still there
there we go
thank god okay
wait i didn't finish it i didn't finish
it
okay cool
uh so we did that where we got admin
didn't didn't bruce turn off the
the thing so that like was laurence just
standing there to try to
clear me and fail does that what just
happened
oh this is this is too stacky the stack
is too stacky
fiction you gonna kill me
okay i'm gonna go back over here and i'm
gonna do this i'm gonna hopefully
doesn't kill me
beautiful [ __ ] off folly
and you too john can everybody [ __ ] up
okay electrically
i feel like i like lawrence oh this is
new question mark
but is it just
exciting it is hello everyone i brought
you all here to discuss the fact that
alana was just sitting at the laser
cannons and the lasers weren't firing
that is because
bruce turned it off my dude okay uh i
was going to say i was clearing lawrence
because i was aware that he was looking
at me to do that and i knew that this
was going to happen
it was like he turned it off he turned
it off stop staring at me
because otherwise you were going to kill
me so lawrence was either staring at me
true anyone seen anything ninja i mean
it doesn't sound like anybody did so i
skipped
okay good talk attack yeah okay cool
yep keep going
volley was with john you saying i
shouldn't be looking at that in chat i
shouldn't be looking at that uh
don't give me hints if i didn't see it i
didn't see it
this you guys can keep talking about
though i'm not gonna take that away from
you i just shouldn't be looking
um okay
let's go do this oh we did it okay
one two three four
one two three four three [ __ ]
how do i always forget on my last one
you stupid idiot what
what
[ __ ] i'm paying attention to people
walking fast and he's doing a terrible
job i don't even see that one
[ __ ] hell alana well at least i'm
alive
one that one two
i have to do this in silence sorry chat
oh [ __ ]
that's where he killed both of us
[Music]
i didn't hear anything all right johnny
so before i say who came out of the
vent does the person who came out of the
van want to reveal themselves
[Laughter]
i was just stuck in one room failing at
the same thing over and over and over
again
certainly no events oh the person who
voted it's ricky
ricky came out of the event all right
ricky it's nice knowing you bud
man richard used to put up such a
defense what happened he was just dead
offense i literally came out of the
venom
i feel like when i'm the imposter i
don't do the vents because that
seems like the most frequent way people
get caught
too risky unfortunate timing too risky
i feel like it's the best way to
yeah i'm used to like the speed being
down a little bit and like usually you
can pop out of a vent before
people come around and see you through
the shadows because it's turned up a bit
i just don't bother with vents at all
because i've gotten caught so many times
the vents are great for escaping but
then like popping back up is
yeah it's such a rough time i just sit
in them did we want to do one more
because that was so short are you guys
going to head out i'll be one more time
i want to do another one where i'm not
imposter
i need to go out accusing someone oh
john already left okay all right so
can we not just add him with the same
room code would it would it not work i
mean i mean
it's only one imposter so we could
probably still do that but yeah
rejoin all right y'all have a good one
uh
[Music]
[ __ ]
i [ __ ] hate this why me you know why
me
[ __ ] kill myself okay
try this the odds are so heavily stacked
against me is my [ __ ] problem here
let's just do that bail jesus christ
like it's just there's just too many of
them and not enough of me
just a dead body inside his head all
right
and where admin and admin yep at the
card reader
jesus i had literally just run in and
farley was standing there by the way
i i was first in the room harley was the
only one in there that i saw and then
someone ran in after us
i started i'm an electrical i saw the
body came off and tried to go report but
i was already there you didn't see the
person who's
there with you no they probably vented
in that bottom corner
because i just went to that update
that's a bit was like no invents
wait so who was in who was in the room
with the body eli
no no i i entered after ricky and ricky
entered after farley
hold up what i feel like who was in the
room by themselves who who was the first
person
was there first folly yes and if no one
invented then it's farley
no no no no no no it's not me i think i
think i think
they vented i started the whole the
upload thing covers your
whole screen except that one sliver on
that far right which i saw immediately
and then jumped off when eli reported
ricky who did you vote there
i voted for harley because uh true but
we just went over that like everyone
hates using the vents
yeah but that could also be that i don't
understand how if you walked into a room
and one person was in it that like short
baby
he wasn't on the body he was on the task
and that task covers your whole screen
her task is at the front of the room and
you were like you would point the finger
at him
i didn't point the finger at him
actually i backed you up that means that
he was near somebody as they got killed
so who was near you farley yeah nobody
was near me like i said there's a vent
right there next to the body
so you guys are tearing me apart i don't
know what to do
all right well it's not fine it's not
it's not farley
notice who voted for farley
it was not falling okay all right
uh i would like to kill eli um but
that's suspicious in it
so uh
i also think that i played that the
exact same way that i always would have
played it
so the logic doesn't quite work i would
have been like he was the first one in
the room let's [ __ ] kill him you know
what i'm saying
but i guess eli doesn't know me um
everybody's sorta you know maybe
together a bit i don't
know what to do here but i'm the one who
prompts everything
that nothing is going to happen unless i
kill someone because i'm the only
[ __ ] one
oh i hate it
can i like give this game
microtransaction money to
um not kill me
just you know just standing near stuff
hoping someone shows up
there's too many of them
ah i just do that i guess just [ __ ]
yeah i don't know we could just
we could just [ __ ] for just for
whatever
oh did i do it
no why what is it oh it has to be one of
the ones that can be done that one
what am i misreading here don't know
hang on hang on oh they have a timer so
i can do communications
there's no way i can i could do this
who cares sure i'm gonna [ __ ] kill
somebody man
i gotta [ __ ] kill somebody it's gonna
take my um
no wrong way it's gonna take my whole
life there's two there's just too many
of you
[ __ ]
beautiful love a good swipe okay just
keep on [ __ ] moving hey
let's just keep [ __ ] moving
wait for that [ __ ] time in a
countdown
[Music]
yeah i only called this to see who was
dead because nobody's reporting bodies
okay i knew there'd be at least one more
okay well i was just in cafeteria bruce
did walk past me i
i've been largely elected ricky because
alana and bruce were in that one room
no diction i was just right next to you
you were in the security room and i was
in reactor doing it i will say i trust
first
i'm just here listen to what i have to
say alana and bruce were in the room
together
i walked out just far enough away and i
stopped and then i went back to see if a
body was left in there because they were
alone for long enough and there wasn't
okay either of them had an opportunity
to kill the other one
they didn't do it oh i've been alone in
a rooster multiple times
i don't know if this is possible or not
maybe i don't know the game well enough
but when the comms went out i saw
addiction fiddling with something
uh that's just wait what his character
stopped his character stopped walking
and then like literally a split second
later the comms went out
um and the only other thing that i'm
okay i think might be it is alana just
because i was scared of alana any time
she got near me
because i'm a woman in the beginning
this is sexist [ __ ] again in it
[Music]
just because i was scared about all
right i've walked by
dickson and alana and not been killed i
think i've really only seen people
like crosstalk several times i'm in a
good also i'm sorry ricky
i'm going to go with lana i'm going to
go i'm going ricky
i'm going right right enjoy your
loss by the way if it's not ricky it's
alana
yeah what oh [ __ ]
that's what's either alana or [ __ ]
christ okay
well [ __ ]
if i just pretend to be scared of them i
gotta [ __ ] kill one of them you know
that's it like how can they even do this
right
don't i just have to kill one of them
isn't that and then i would win the
whole thing
oh they have like no tasks left i gotta
do this quickly
[ __ ]
[Music]
yeah it was me you guys it was 100 me i
don't know how i won
you didn't you did you didn't oh i got
defeated okay okay got it
got it you guys finished your tasks you
finished your tasks got it got it got it
got it yeah it was how did you finish
your task for the cafeteria
because i had no more tasks to do and i
was like i don't want to be alone in
security so
i think it was a ghost i think it was a
ghost i should have been sabotaging you
to get more time but i only realized
that the
at the very end that you guys were so
close that i was like i just need to
find one of you then just [ __ ] kill
you and then i'd be fine
i wouldn't leave bruce aside i was like
no like six and i were circling
even if she killed one of you oh but it
wouldn't have mattered yeah if i had
even been with
the two of you but i thought that you
split up at the start too so i could
have just [ __ ] swiped one of you and
it wouldn't have mattered anyway
right at the start you would have won
that's true but the countdown timer
is there at this time yeah if you
sabotage you could have isolated one of
them
i don't tend to sabotage uh because like
generally i feel like that that puts
everyone in the same place and i prefer
to just find people randomly and keep
walking that's how i kill people
is so that no one ever spots me i just
[ __ ] run past them so i don't like
doing it but i should have banned
if you've gone to reactor yeah you've
done that one stood on one of the two
spots as soon as somebody showed up you
just
could have killed them i would have been
good i would have won it you're right i
should have sabotaged
oh somebody showed the code all right i
guess i'll write down anyways yeah i
think we're done
yeah good playing with you guys that was
a very fun game good games everybody
i knew to pick that up super quickly
all right uh bruce hit me up whenever i
will
do it again the [ __ ] guilt you guys
i hate it so like my face is red i hate
it i hate being the impulsa
i hate it so [ __ ] much
like it's just the worst um yeah like i
said i don't tend to sabotage because i
feel like it brings them together and
then it's easy to get spotted my strat
as you can tell i have been successful
is kill and run
um but i should have in the end there
but i've also never i don't think ever
played around where i was the only
imposter
which obviously is like a lot of
pressure
[ __ ] hate it got a lot of wins there
you know um
also died more than normal that too
that's the that's the name of the game a
lot of variety in there thank you all
for watching i almost yeah i almost won
again
i feel like chad is talking [ __ ] but i
did very good as the imposter
and i appreciate those of you who are
recognizing that thank you
i got real [ __ ] close there i just
needed to find one of them or two of
them
which i hadn't even considered real
close real [ __ ] close
um thank you guys for watching see you
guys next time bye